welcome back to las vegas now one of our
local faves founders coffee is expanding
and this time inside la bonito
supermarket in green valley so coffee
expert mercy riccio is here to tell us
about this marriage between la bonita
and founders coffee why was this the
perfect marriage oh well we're the new
sister
restaurant um inside la bonita we are
sister to the saint rose location
founders the durango
founders
uh we've been open since april uh no i'm
sorry since uh september 16th wow okay
how's it been going people are coming
it's going pretty good we've got a few
dishes that we do not offer at the other
two locations that were made
specifically just for la bonita location
we have the moleta toast
so this is combining the founders
traditional foods like the avocado toast
and all in that and yes we still have
the avocado toast we still have the lox
toes bagels your traditional
specialty coffees
that we all know and love okay let's
talk about it okay so we've added the
molete toast which i'll have beans
cheese we top it off with pico de gallo
oh my gosh that's so perfect that is a
hearty breakfast with flavor i love it
and then we also have the elote toast
and that's going to have corn cortez
mayonnaise a little bit of lime and
tahini on top can i try that one sure
yeah send that to me while you talk
about the next one
and then this one is our churro toast
and it's going to have the honey cream
cheese along with nutella
and
churros
so it's sweet it's like a dessert toast
as well as the fresh leches wow and now
i have someone throwing in my teeth
this is so good and i can just imagine
coming in and grabbing a few for the day
just really quick snacks too
but most importantly the drinks so can
we talk about what special drinks you
guys have there we've had we've added
lemonades and teas
so this one is our strawberry kiwi
lemonade oh my gosh and this is
something special to la bonita you guys
have you have to come and find it just
here
delicious
oh my gosh that is refreshing
that is so refreshing what's this one
this one is our mango tea
and our mango is topped off with a
little hint of mint
it's my producer ask can you save this
one for her
yes natalia we can't we can't okay so
with the tea we're making avocado toast
okay so now the avocado toast you can
find at all the locations but the
specialty items are just at our location
this is our quiche which is our chorizo
it's our take on our breakfast
on our breakfast uh quiche only we added
um
refried beans and chorizo pico de gallo
bell peppers polenta cheese it's really
tasty
okay and how do you guys separate the
founders toast the now the founders
slash la bonita toast from all the other
avocado toast in town
i think what makes us more special is
that we'll do
we'll top our avocado with the pico de
gallo or you can add a lot to your
avocado toast as well i got so something
unique if you guys are going into la
bonita you already have great taste so
this is the perfect addition thank you
so much thank you and hope to see
everybody in green valley at la bonita
thank you julian awesome to you